we use algorithms all the time
algorithms are sets of instructions to
do something okay
so that just like the recipes in a
cookbook they're interesting for
computers and TVs because computers
actually aren't very good at making
sense of things okay so they do exactly
what the instruction says let's think of
a really simple one washing your hair
shampoo so normally I don't see wet hair
that's an algorithm you wet your hair
you apply the shampoo you wash and then
you rinse and each of these are
instructions and each of these
instructions are chained together in
order to give you essentially a little
bit of what we'd call a program so that
makes sense you know what that means
so some shampoo bottles have that so you
also know what that means it means you
do it place computer wouldn't know that
and would perpetually wash your hair so
you'd never have dry hair so designing
those algorithms and understanding them
it's core to how we think as computer
scientists how then do you understand if
things will stop what's called termini
how long will they take to do things
understanding how costly those
algorithms are and whether they have
certain properties like they work as
important okay so the algorithm for the
assembly of furniture at IKEA we may
argue and many people do rather
violently argue that they don't work
they've messed something out they've
forgotten to tell you something
understanding the equivalent in a
computer system is what algorithm design
and algorithm analysis is about so to
give you another example of that an
algorithm to get from here to London so
not seem to London I won't say not seems
in the Midlands so you need to head
south that's one stales not exactly a
great set of instructions so this again
is the next thing that happened you have
to figure out what the appropriate
levels of instruction is to do that okay
so that it's more of an instruction
rather than a a big suggestion right and
so let's try again so going to London
okay
us to the train station get on train get
the tree into some Pancras get off so
that's one course at an algorithm but
you could also say get a taxi get in
your car drive to London get oh you
could see fly private helicopter picks
you up I would say this building flies
you direct the certain London drops you
off note all of those algorithms all
achieve the same end they get you from
here to London but they're all different
aren't they at all a bit and some of
them sound about preposterous as I've
said them as well but they all have two
properties that I think are important to
think about okay how much do they cost
because obviously renting a helicopter
got to be pricier even today still prays
here than getting a ticket on the train
and driving with fuel prices and we'll
have another cost Oh and so that cost is
important and they'll also have
different speeds one would envisage the
helicopter getting there faster and then
the train and the Train probably being a
bit bit slower than the car so each of
those kind of costs and performances are
important okay and so a lot of what we
do is analyze and cost and performance
how much resource do we have to use to
do the algorithm and then how fast will
it be on what will achieve and how will
it do that and what's what we do in
computing is to actually figure out the
best algorithm the best set of
instructions and the best tactic for
those sets of instructions to do that so
things like sorting a set of numbers
becomes important not that you
eventually get a sorted set of numbers
but they're done fast enough and that
the cost of doing it is low enough